it's almost Christmas and many of you
are probably planning on praying over
the next few days which is why I want to
take this opportunity to warn you that
if you do plan to pray
and you happen to be in Britain that
could land you in jail
before I ask you any questions about
what's going on today I have to caution
you which is just your rights which is
you do not have to say anything it might
harm your defense if you do not mention
one question something which you later
on in Courtney can you send me
what are you here for today
uh physically understanding here okay
why here of all places I know we don't
live nearby I think this is an abortion
or something okay basketball
is you standing here part of the protest
no
praying I might be playing in my head
um so I'll ask you once more will you
voluntarily come with us now to the
police station for me to ask you some
questions about today and other days
where there are allegations that you've
broken up in space
if I've got a choice then though okay
well then you're under arrest the class
suspicion of the planning to compile in
the public space it's a protection order
2014 . I'll post you again you do not
have to say anything you may harm your
defense if you didn't mention one
question something which you later on in
court is when you do say maybe
now I would like to think that this sort
of evil police action cartoonishly evil
police action is only taking place in
the United Kingdom
but it's happening here too the FBI
regularly and increasingly targets
pro-lifers who prey outside of abortion
Mills and then they arrest them on
trumped-up charges that the pro-lifers
are obstructing or intimidating people
who are seeking to kill their children
the UK might be a little bit ahead of
the curve here but not by much people
are being arrested for praying
silently in their heads
and I love my country and I love my
ancestral country Great Britain and I
love my whole civilization and I have
always been raised to believe that we
are the good guys but in recent decades
we've sanctioned the killing of almost a
million babies a year in recent years
we've essentially abolished marriage
we've started grooming and castrating
little kids and pumping them full of
hormones and mutilating their bodies and
now we're arresting Christians for
praying silently in their heads so
I don't want to be a downer or anything
but I've got to ask a very British
question
are we the Baddies
I'm Michael Knowles it's the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from tme Shu who
says zelenski played Congress the same
way he plays the piano
I'm not going to explain that one if you
want to find out you got to look it up
but I don't recommend that you do look
it up I recommend that you spend time
with your families this Christmas season
and if you can't spend time with your
families maybe the crazy storm systems
have shut down your flights I recommend
you call your families using pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com enter code
Knowles are you tired of overpaying for
your wireless network get talk text and
blazing fast data for just thirty
dollars a month Pure Talk gives you the
same network the same towers and the
same coverage as the other guys at half
the price Merry Christmas everyone I
love pure talk it has saved me a ton of
money it's an amazing service and you
can switch incredibly easily if you're
talking to us-based customer service
team makes the switch super fast you can
feel good knowing that you were
supporting a veteran-owned business and
here's the best part
when you go to puretalk.com and enter
code at nulls you will save an
additional 50 off your first month there
is no reason to pay Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile over 80 a month for wireless
service when you can get the same
service on the same network at Pure Talk
for half the price go to puretalk.com
enter code Knowles kwles to save 50 off
your first month that is puretalk.com
promo code Knowles for fifty percent off
your first month Pure Talk simply
smarter Wireless
are we the baddies are we the baddies
speaking of our civilization projecting
our power abroad there's a new
there's a new academic report
that the United States Marines have
received
demanding that they stop calling their
drill instructors sir and ma'am
so our Marines are wonderful Brave
Valiant Marines who sacrifice a lot to
defend our country and our way of life
they sign up and they end up working for
these woke lunatics who tell them that
they they can't call their drill
instructors sir or ma'am
because they might misgender the drill
instructor
this according to a 739-page report from
the University of Pittsburgh
this was catalyzed by a new
Congressional mandate so it's our stupid
politicians forcing this nonsense on the
Marines It's featured PhD biologists
Bradley C nindl and Mita lovalecker and
22 academics telling marines that they
need to quote replace gendered
identifiers for instance for example sir
or ma'am in the primary salutation or
response to drill instructors with
gender neutral language such as drill
instructor or senior drill instructor
senior di or SDI employing gender
neutral identifiers eliminates the
possibility of misgendering drill
instructors which can unintentionally
offend or cause Discord
[Music]
we're never going to win another War
again are we we had a good run the U.S
did a pretty good job winning wars for
most of our history
are men and women in uniform or just as
tough as Nails as they always have been
but if the people leading our military
foreign
they're afraid of
misgendering we're not going to win
anymore that's so maybe we've still got
a little bit of Gusto left in us but as
long as long as these military leaders
remain in place we are totally screwed
which is not great because the United
States whether we want to admit it or
not administers a global Empire
we don't make laws like the bill up on
Capitol Hill we're not just little
Nation surrounded by oceans we have a
global Empire we have States overseas
we've got one state Hawaii just in the
middle of the Pacific we have
basically total control over the
European continent because we are the
military for Europe that's what NATO
does We Run The United Nations so we
have a role as the world superpower and
we are currently fighting an Imperial
War
with Russia over the territory of
Ukraine and whether Ukraine will join
NATO or join the European Union or
become part of Russia or maintain a kind
of quasi-independence that that allows
it to be a buffer state to play great
Powers off of one another
you saw this when our vassal Vladimir
zielinski came over to the U.S and
lobbied for more money so that we will
help fund that war against Russia
and the Democrats were happy to have him
they flew him out here to use him and
the the
emotion behind the war in Ukraine to
convince Republicans to vote for this
stupid Omnibus spending package the 1.7
trillion dollar spending package some of
which will go toward funding this war in
Ukraine and one of the images that came
out of this whole
episode was it's a doctored image it's
not it's not an authentic image but it's
an image of Nancy Pelosi and other
congressmen holding up an American flag
but then the bottom of the American flag
is no longer red and white
it's yellow and blue it's the Ukrainian
flag
and the Stars it's no longer all the
stars it's got these little Ukrainian
symbols there too
so it's not it's not a real image
but
it does refer to a real sense I think
all these big Libs changing their
profile pictures and their their names
on social media to include the Ukrainian
flag
which is crazy
I love my family is Italian I love Italy
I'm not going to put an Italian flag in
my handle because I'm an American I'm
not an Italian that's disloyal to do
that
I've got British ancestry as I mentioned
in the open I'm not going to put the
Union Jack in my head because that's but
all these Libs they're putting the
Ukrainian flag and then I was looking at
that I said wow this is the new the new
Imperial standard the red white and blue
with the Ukraine thing at the bottom and
I thought well if we're going to have an
imperial flag
I guess America and Ukraine as a mashup
is better than the current Imperial
standard which is just the pride flag
that is effectively the flag of the
American Empire it's the flag we raise
over our conquered territories overseas
it's the flag that the liberal
imperialists all use they all prefer the
rainbow flag to the red white and blue
it's a flag that denotes not just a
particular place with a particular
people as the American flag does as all
other national flags do but it denotes
Universal values so it it really does
denote a global Empire of liberalism so
you have all of these Libs we use these
kind of flags they never talk about
the nation and the people in the
particular interests of the United
States it's always this abstract stuff
it's always spreading democracy
spreading human rights spreading gay
rights spreading this right in that
right and all these abstract Concepts
all over the world that is a claim of
domination that is a claim of
imperialism saying that individual
Nations have no right to rule themselves
people who have
their own Traditions have no right to
maintain those traditions and this is
the most important part as far as I'm
concerned
even we conservatives here in America
have no right to our own Traditions
Christians here in America here in
Britain here all over the West have no
right to our own traditions we don't get
to go to church they're going to shut
down the churches during covet they're
going to leave the pot stores open
they're going to leave the casinos open
but they're going to shut down the
churches and then even after they reopen
the churches after covid they're not
going to let you pray
silently
outside of an abortion
Clinic that's the problem for me the
problem for me is not even so much this
debate between nationalism and
imperialism or nationalism and globalism
in the way that politics is actually
functioning today that is an important
distinction
but
the Middle Ages were great and there was
plenty of empire in the Middle Ages
nationalism is in many ways a product of
liberal modernity so it's not just that
I'm some hardcore nationalist far from
it
but if we're going to have imperialism
if we're going to have an Empire I'd
like it to be a good Christian Empire
where we get to keep our traditions and
worship God correctly and we don't get
arrested for praying
what we have instead is this hideous
liberal atheistic kind of Empire that
that promotes all the worst aspects of
our culture and suppresses all the best
parts of it well I don't think we want
any part of that and that is why you'll
hear Republicans being called Putin
Stooges and appeasers and all the rest
because we don't care about the war in
Ukraine well that's why it's about a lot
more than Ukraine it's about this
question of if we are going to
administer a global Empire if we're
going to spread our values around the
world
what values are we spreading are we
spreading truth justice and God and
religion and virtue and family and
prosperity or
are we spreading abortion and transiting
to kids and and arresting people for
praying what is it unfortunately right
now it's the latter is it any wonder
that we don't want to fund the Empire no
we want to get back to basics we want to
get back to religion we want to get back
to God when you want to do that you've
got to check out Bible in a year with
father Mike Schmitz right now head on
over to ascensionpress.com if you are
someone who has always wanted to read
and understand the Bible but you're not
sure where to start check out the Bible
in a year podcast from Ascension the
Bible in a year podcast is currently the
most popular religion podcast in the US
millions of people have listened to it
twice it's hit the number one spot on
Apple podcasts it is the only podcast
that I reliably listen to in the Bible
in a year father Mike Schmitz reads the
entire Bible in 365 daily episodes
providing helpful commentary reflection
and prayer along the way what better way
to start the new year you can find the
Bible in your podcast with father Mike
Schmitz for free at your favorite
podcast app or YouTube plus you can
follow along with a special reading plan
to help you better understand the story
go check it out right now
ascensionpress.com Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s so that you can start reading
and more importantly understanding the
Bible this year
head on over there download the reading
plan for free that is ascensionpress.com
Knowles
to download the reading plan for free
speaking of the rainbow flag
did you know that I
am apparently an
anti-lgbtq bigot
that's true that according to Media
Matters apparently Media Matters has a
rundown of Tim Poole's guests from the
year and they say extremists bigots and
conspiracy theorists YouTube YouTuber
timples 2022 guests in review
and I was really honored to make the
list it's sort of a best of so they go
through all these guys you know let's
see where am I I want to skip over
everybody else I just want to get to me
they've got I think a number of other
daily wire people did too okay here we
go
uh top of the page far right figure
Lauren Southern was on Tim cast multiple
times this year Southern has a history
of pushing racist propaganda and white
nationalist rhetoric and then you get to
me the daily wires Michael Knowles is an
anti-lgbtq bully pool hosted Knowles in
April by the way pool hosted Knowles
like five days ago too so they clearly
aren't up on their extremism
and then it goes on and on but I think I
think Brett made it I think Walsh made
it Jeremy I mean there yeah here we go
Ben Ben's on here it's it's kind of like
maybe Drew all of us
but I I ranked up here as an anti-lgbtq
bully
I
performed in my few first musical
theater production at the age of eight
when I was a child I took
Jazz Ballroom
and tap dancing lessons
I graduated from the gayest university
in the United States
I have lived most of my life
on the coasts
a disproportionate number of my friends
are very very gay
I regularly drink port and Sherry at the
end of the night I
I just I just how did I become I like to
think I'm a nice open mind how did I
become an
anti-lgbtq bully do you know why you
know what they cite they get a link that
that phrase It's because
I said on Tim Poole's show
or maybe it was on my own show I don't
remember exactly the context I said that
there's no such thing as gay marriage
that marriage intrinsically involves
sexual difference and so because I
stated a plain fact of language and
anthropology
that makes me an anti-lgbtq bully why do
I mention it one I mention it because I
absolutely adore my publicists over at
Media Matters I thank them very much for
keeping me in the news and top of
everybody's mind
the other reason I mention it is to show
you what a lie it was when when the left
told us when we were a little further up
that slippery slope
they said
listen
why do you care what people do in their
own homes
say well it's not exactly what we're
talking we're talking about political
matters you know the nature of marriage
the nature of man and woman and the
nature of the Constitution and what the
degree to which the Constitution even
has a say over these sorts of matters
and so they said well you're a come on
you're just you're just being a weirdo
why do you care what people do in their
homes okay we said do whatever you want
in your own homes okay we'll even
pretend that it's in the Constitution
that you have a right to do whatever
weird sex stuff you want to do in your
homes okay fine
all right and that's why we also need
civil unions that's all we just want
civil unions okay
just just recognize that certain legal
privileges that you can have them in a
union between two men
just as between a man and a woman
I said I don't know because it kind of
then blurs the definition they said what
do you care why are you come on that's
all we want okay
then they said we're going to redefine
marriage they said well hold on man
marriage that's the fundamental
political institution that's a that's
for all of human history everywhere in
the world people have thought marriage
means a certain thing now you're telling
me it doesn't mean that at all you're
actually abolishing the institution of
marriage so that's all we want to do
that's all we want to do is just
redefine marriage a little bit but you
can you guys you can still it's not
going to threaten your marriage
you can run your business you can have
your life you can have your church okay
then what did they do they just passed
this quote unquote respect for Marriage
Act which Outlaws
businesses refusing to participate in a
gay marriage quote unquote gay marriage
now if you are a Christian all I did
was articulate the Catholic view of
marriage which also happens to be with
some exception the Protestant view of
marriage which also happens to be the
Jewish view of marriage which also
happens to be the Muslim view of
marriage which also happens to be the
view of marriage of every
even semi-reasonable agnostic or atheist
for all Pagan for all of human history
they say it makes you a bully that's how
it goes
and had we stood a little firmer on our
principles and on reality further up
that slippery slope and had we not
allowed the libs and the squishes to
tell us to stop being such fuddy-duddies
and to just you know come on get with
the times and get hip and cool man we
wouldn't be where we are now all of the
sexual Madness that you were seeing the
castrating little kids The Pride flags
flying everywhere from our state
capitals to Kandahar the the
uh now prohibition of people to refuse
to participate in a so-called gay
marriage
all of that flows directly from those
those battles that we conceded further
up the slippery slope should it should
remind us of how to fight moving into
the future
now beyond the Empire of the rainbow
beyond the American Empire abroad
the political order is a little bit
shaky at home there was a really really
dumb piece in Vox Fox is a left-wing
outlet they call themselves explanatory
journalism
but I love that descriptor explanatory
journalism as opposed to really dumb
stupid doesn't teach you anything
journalism which I guess describes most
journalism actually but Vox I say we're
very we're a very special kind of
Journalism we explain things
unlike all those dumb idiotic
journalistic Outlets so the headline is
Sotomayor and Kagan need to think about
retiring
the U.S Senate is fundamentally broken
institution Democratic judges need to
account for that in their retirement
decisions it's by illen nilheiser who's
a big lib he is a senior correspondent
at Fox and he's focused on the Supreme
Court the decline of liberal democracy
in the United States fine by me I
certainly America was not founded to be
a liberal democracy it should not be a
liberal democracy the phrase liberal
democracy only came to describe the
United States really in the middle to
late part of the 20th century so forget
about that but you get you get where
he's coming from and he says we've now
lived with the consequences of Ruth
Bader ginsburg's late life arrogance
for more than two years
arrogance you see the Arrogant RBG
decided she wasn't going to retire she
was going to
die in office die on the bench
and then she was replaced
and she was replaced by a conservative
and this was terrible according to
milheiser
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
much like other justices
on the left and on the right have said
no we are not going to time our
retirement decisions
to when a president of our party
is in office because we're judges we are
not supposed to be partisan obviously we
have partisan leanings obviously we were
appointed by presidents sometimes the
justices disappoint the presidents and
the parties that appoint them but
there's the idea at least is that
they're supposed to be above the petty
squabbling of partisan politics
we need at least one institution to at
least pretend to do that at least some
of the time Ian milheiservox.com totally
completely wrong here what they are
doing is expressing the worst kind of
degrading leveling Tendencies of
democracy
we in the United States
have a broadly democratic government
it's not purely a democratic government
but it's there's a big Democratic
representation
and we don't have a monarchy here we
have elements of monarchy in the
presidency but we don't have a monarchy
we explicitly don't have a monarchy and
whenever you think about monarchy a lot
of Americans hate the idea of monarchy
but one of the good things that monarchy
does is it gives a nation a kind of
dignity
at least in the Pomp and the
circumstance if not in the personal
comportment of the monarchs though in
Britain you just had one of the most
dignified monarchs in history but but
even just the Pomp and Circumstance even
just the big castles and the grand
parades it gives the nation a sense of
dignity that the Monarch as Sovereign
gives the nation a sense that there is
something above just the petty little
squabbling over this tax policy or that
tax policy this is why the Royals are
not permitted to behave in a party
political sort of way
because you you want the country to look
up and say oh there's something that
unifies all of us in the United States
because we're not a monarchy the Supreme
Court has served that function before
that it's above the election cycles that
it's above public opinion polls that it
it the building that it operates in is
one of the grandest buildings in our
country
it's a big nice solid Grand building
with nice big serious columns and the
justices they don't wear business suits
they wear robes and they're they're
supposed to elevate themselves Above
This that that's why they hang out
together that's why Scalia and Ruth
Bader Ginsburg were buddies and they'd
go riding camels and or elephants rather
and things to go on vacation okay they
were friends I think they were genuinely
friends but it was important to see that
they were friends Sotomayor and Clarence
Thomas apparently are kind of friends
good to see that
America needs something like that
but the leveling Democrats don't want us
to have any dignity at all they want to
take us all right down to the gutter and
and totally got the last institution
that ever even sometimes kind of lends
itself to dignity
it's not good it's a big fight we're in
we gotta we gotta amp ourselves up for
the fight that's why I got to check out
Black Rifle coffee right now head on
over to Black riflecoffee.com use promo
code Knowles Black Rifle coffee company
is helping you knock out your Christmas
shopping with a ton of great new
products this year designed for people
who love country and coffee you can shop
Brewing gear thermoses mugs apparel for
10 off with promo code Knowles kwles
Black Rifle sources the most exotic
roasts from around the globe all coffee
is roasted right here in the good old us
of a by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes DW plus kitchens
are stocked with Black Rifle coffee
yours can be to the Knolls house is
stocked with it too head on over to
Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
Knolls kwels for 10 off coffee Coffee
Gear apparel or when you sign up for a
new coffee Club subscription that's
black riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles
K NWA s for 10 off Black Rifle coffee
supporting America's veterans and
America's coffee
just before we all break for Christmas
the Senate has passed that ridiculous
Omnibus Bill
1.7 trillion dollar spending package
pass it on Thursday with a 68 to 29 vote
with at least 18 Republicans joining
Democrats to push this massive Omnibus
Over The Line
the Republican Senators who voted for it
were
all The Usual Suspects the Romney's of
the world but even some who are
generally pretty good
they voted for it too really really
pathetic I made the point on the show
yesterday that
no Republican needed to vote for this
spending Bill no Republican needed to do
it the Democrats could just have owned
it
the the
Republicans are about to take over the
house
that will give the Republicans a lot
more leverage because spending bills
first of all originate in the house and
the house is needed to get them through
to get it up to the presidency they
could have passed
a short-term spending plan if they
wanted to avoid the government shutdown
and then they could have had a proper
debate about this in January
they didn't do it because they didn't
want to do it
the Republicans who voted for this
didn't vote for it because they had to
because what else would happen we'd the
government would shut down the war and
Ukraine would collapse the whatever
whatever nonsense
they certainly didn't vote for it
because it was going to take on any
problems that Americans actually care
about like the southern border or the
economy they didn't do that the bill is
going to make inflation much worse and
the border is wide open and while we're
all debating this bill Joe Biden is
flying illegal aliens into red States
like my own state of Tennessee so it's
not that at all the Republicans who
voted for this wanted to vote for it
because we are very often governed not
by two parties fighting each other tooth
and nail over principle and policy but
rather by a uniparty that that sometimes
Duke's thing Duke Duke out issues in the
performance of opposition but it's
really a false opposition
now the house can move on to really
serious business
now they can finally get into really
serious things such as
releasing Trump's tax returns
remember the other day when Mitch
McConnell he was interviewed about the
omnibusiness
the number one priority for Republicans
to the war and Ukraine
remember when he he did that
this might be even more ridiculous than
that some Republicans care about the war
in Ukraine I don't know a single
Republican who cares about Trump's taxes
and so there's the house the house is
Wiley Coyote and they're chasing they're
chasing the Road Runner Donald Trump and
they say we've got him now and they've
got the Acme Anvil and they say we're
going to release his tax returns the
walls are closing in we've got him
do they have him
you listening out there
probably
disproportionately conservative and
Republican many of you I'm sure love
Donald Trump many of you probably don't
like Donald Trump that much whatever you
think about Trump
is there anything that could be in
Donald Trump's taxes that would change
your opinion of him
anything anything like I don't think
there's really bad stuff in there in
fact in the last tax fraud case against
the Trump organization the one that was
brought up in New York what they
discovered was that Trump was actually
overpaying his taxes in that he was
artificially inflating the value of his
businesses to try to get better loans
and it was a kind of a complex thing but
I don't think there's gonna be bad stuff
but even if there were let's say that
Donald Trump were I don't know paying
off the mob to do some construction
project in New York and doing this and
burying a body here and would would any
of that
change your opinion of Donald Trump no
of course not
so I assume this will be an absolutely
they're just they're just throwing
spaghetti at the wall they just want to
stop this guy and it's a reminder that
the Democrats keep trying to stop this
guy and kill his campaign in the Cradle
why
it is not because they think that Donald
Trump is so super easy to beat in 2024.
if they really believed if Democrats
were making a BET right now that Donald
Trump is the easiest candidate for them
to beat in 2024
they would be doing everything they can
to make sure he's the nominee and they
would be doing everything they can to
kill Ron DeSantis campaign in the Cradle
or kill Tim Scott's campaign in the
Cradle or kill Nikki Haley's or Mike
Pence's or Mike pompeo's or Ted Cruz's
or any or any Buddies
only some of these people have actually
said that they are running or will run
but there are plenty people Josh Hawley
or whoever there are a lot of people who
could run
but they're going after Trump why
because though they tell us that that
Trump will be super duper easy to beat
they don't seem to believe it themselves
speaking of changing Minds
there's a story
another bit of a downer story well
luckily we'll have an upper before we we
all head into Christmas with the mailbag
in the voicemail bag make sure you get
your questions in for after after we
come back from Christmas
a little bit of a downer Church
attendance and general belief in in God
has dropped in the United States
over the past few years
no surprise there
kovid appeared to accelerate the trend
Church attendance has dropped by roughly
45 percent
since the start of the covid lockdowns
a Gallup survey released over the summer
found that belief in God sunk to an
all-time low this year down to 81
percent
it also identified young individuals and
leftists as being the most likely not to
believe in God nothing really surprising
there it's actually somewhat
edifying or gratifying that at least 81
percent of people still sort of at least
believe in God
but the key here is
shutting down the churches
coincided not only with a drop in belief
in God but with an acceleration of a
drop in the belief in God
and I suspect it was probably the main
driver and it gets back to a principle
that we sometimes talk about on the show
which is the principle Lex orondi Lex
credendi
the way that you worship will determine
the way that you believe
and it's we've been using all sorts of
Latin phrases on the show this we got
vox populi Vox day from Elon Musk now
we've got this Alexa Randy Lex
credential it's really important and
there's there is an Impulse even among
modern Christian people to say well it
doesn't matter how I pray I don't need
to pray on my knees I don't need to
receive the sacraments I don't need to
go to church in person I can just do it
all kind of in my head no you can't you
are a body you're a soul but you're also
a body and we live in time and space and
you gotta actually do this stuff and
when you pray and when you go to church
and when you have Christmas dinner don't
forget they shut down our Christmas
dinners too and you have your family
over and you even read Twas the Night
Before Christmas you've been engaged in
certain certain rituals that are
not religious or only tangentially
religious or but you you do these things
that are associated with your religion
you are more likely to believe in your
religion because we are not pure reason
we're not just brains floating in the
air or something like that we're bodies
you got to get it in your muscle memory
this is why if you want to memorize a
poem or a speech or a script or
something
it helps to say it out loud really
exaggerate your your mouth movements
because you get it in that muscle memory
if you want to get good at a sport I am
reliably informed what you got to do is
you got to swing that bat a lot you got
to get it into your muscle memory you
don't just read it in a book and think
about it you don't even just read it in
your Bible and think about that and pray
in your head people are getting arrested
out there for praying even silently even
in their own head so I get why people
are intimidated do not be intimidated
do not let these liberal secularist
atheist jerks get you down stomp on your
joy especially at Christmas time don't
forget our Lord has overcome the world
Christmas Is Almost Here it's almost
officially here it's we're just a couple
days away many of you are already daily
wire Plus members and you get to enjoy
the great content that we have released
this year what is a woman Terror on the
Prairie the greatest lie ever sold if
you've not been able to enjoy it because
you're not a member then take advantage
of our 30 holiday sale this also applies
to gift membership so do not miss this
opportunity to get everyone on your list
an annual gift membership from daily
wire plus with code holiday at checkout
since joining the or plus Jordan
Peterson has just ramped up his already
busy schedule and we've been reaping the
rewards earlier this fall Jordan and our
production team went to Washington DC to
film a beautiful and engaging
documentary on the Museum of the Bible
called logos and literacy in it Jordan
meets with historians theologians and
philosophers to discuss the history of
the Bible and its influence on the world
Jordan sent us a note to say how happy
he was with the way it turned out he
actually watched it twice and I I
imagine he said something like I really
really
not
that was a very good piece of film I
don't know what he actually said but I
know he said it in a very compelling
Canadian sort of voice no doubt you will
want to do the same the only way you can
is if you're a daily wire plus member so
sign up today
finally finally we've arrived at my
favorite time of the week
the mailbag sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan and enter
code nulls kwles to get 50 off your
first month take it away
hi Michael it's Elise again I wanted to
press you further about a question you
received last week about how a wife can
serve her husband
I have also been searching for an answer
to this question my husband is very
self-sufficient and rarely asked me to
do anything for him I feel like there is
this higher goal that God is calling me
to as a wife that I'm not reaching
simply by doing his laundry when he
hasn't done it himself or cooking him
dinner or things like that all the
resources about marriage I've looked
into seem to be encouraging the wife to
ask for more from her husband and rarely
do they acknowledge God's design for a
woman to serve and a man to love which
is frustrating if you have any specific
examples of deeper ways to fulfill this
calling or if it really is just about
the everyday tasks that make his life
easier I would love to hear it thanks so
much and God bless you
based
very very is that what the kids call it
these days thank you so much for that
excellent question your hunch is right
serving your husband and acting in the
role of a wife and a mother and the
matriarch of a family is not just about
the little things
the little things are a huge part of it
because women excel at the little things
in a way that men do not men seek after
big glorious Endeavors all the time and
frankly we often neglect the little
things that most productive work is
actually made of so we we not are not
nearly as organized as women are we're
often not as meticulous or fastidious in
in certain sort of banal tasks as as
women can be so those little acts of
love you know cooking breakfast for your
husband or
doing the laundry or whatever those
those really do matter but there is much
more to that to
being a wife in a marriage than just
that I think with sweet little Elisa
she's the only person that I allow to
write my show that I beg to write my
show because she she gets it you know
and it's not just that she and I have
the same mind it's not we don't really
have the same mind we have complementary
Minds she compliments things that I miss
that I don't quite see she sees it and
she can say it and we speak the same
language and we often and this is true
of married couples
we often don't even need to speak to to
be able to communicate just a little
glance or just a little look and that
happens more and more over time the
longer that you are married
part I don't know exactly how to
establish that
uh
but you you have to
I don't know I and I don't know what
your husband does so you know certain
jobs are going to lend themselves more
to this than others sweet little Elisa
listens to my show every single day
because I of course force her to no she
voluntarily listens to my show and
she'll give me thoughts on it and it's
always constructive and it's it's
she's just really plugged in she knows
exactly what I am doing probably more so
than I even know what she is doing and I
live where she works you know and I I am
the father of the children who she is
raising and you know the other things
that she's doing as well but we're just
so
plugged in on what each other is is
doing that I can say it can be 10
o'clock at night I'll be lying there
I'll say I don't know what to talk about
and she'll say oh yeah well did you see
this thing today you got to put this in
the show and then I think that you know
not only did this woman cook me dinner
and clean my clothing she just wrote my
show too she just did my whole my whole
show it's pretty good you you want to be
involved in pretty much every aspect of
your lives together next question
hello Miguel you have talked about the
rapidly decreasing sperm count since the
1950s Joe Rogan has had on several
people as well discussing this over the
past couple years given this if the
trend continues aren't we as a society
obligated to embrace more artificial
forms of reproduction like IVF don't get
me wrong I don't like the idea of this
at all but if it continues to get harder
and harder to reproduce and we do
nothing as a society say decreasing
pesticides petrochemicals Banning vegans
do we have any other choice as a species
also as a note I expect this problem to
continue especially with the Trans
agenda making a bunch of our kids
infertile I guess the question is would
God rather our species go extinct or
have some fertilized eggs frozen away
it's a tough question
I don't think it's a tough question
because good ends do not justify immoral
means
and I think that IVF is intrinsically
immoral
and I know it's a tough one because a
lot of people out there got their kids
through IVF and a lot of people out
there may have been conceived themselves
through IVF
this is not to say that you're certainly
going to burn in hell
this is not to say that the kids can see
through IVF are not as valuable as the
kids can see not through IVF
any more than it would be to say that a
kid can see through rape is is somehow
not as valuable as a kid conceived in
the conjugal act between a married
mother and father
but it is to say that certain actions
are immoral and I think that in the case
of IVF
it's immoral for one you're separating
the conjugal act from the procreative
ACT which is disordered and I think
ravely sinful even if you're not willing
to go with me that far
you are establishing the domination of
technology and Industry and perhaps even
the state over the origin and Destiny of
human life very very dangerous and I
think quite immoral third the way that
you get the male contribution to IVF is
uh
intrinsically disordered and deeply
shameful and the sort of thing that when
one does it one closes one's blind so
there's a good reason for that so that
you wouldn't want to you wouldn't want
to do that either and uh and then of
course that's you those are the four
problems before you even get to the
issue of you're creating human beings in
a Petri dish and then freezing them away
indefinitely
not acceptable and then in some cases
you're implanting them and then it
doesn't catch and then you people will
kill them for abortion if if too many of
the embryos catch in the womb so and and
this doesn't even take into account what
happens when people mix up the Petri
dishes and they put they put the wrong
baby into the wrong mother and it
doesn't it doesn't take into account
what happens through surrogacy where
women are basically rented out as as
cattle you know they're rented out as
just vessels by wealthy gay men or or
even just wealthy couples who struggle
with infertility so the whole process is
immoral and you wouldn't you wouldn't
see it necessarily when you just think
well I want to have a kid and you know
this is a technology to do it what could
be wrong isn't that pro-life no it is a
good end the kid is a good end but good
ends do not justify immoral means
another reason is
that the sperm counts have dropped in no
small part because people are just
fatter and lazier than they used to be
so obesity is skyrocketed and sedentary
life Styles have become much more
widespread but there are multiple
studies that show that when people lose
some weight when guys lose some weight
and get off the couch their sperm count
jumps back up pretty quickly maybe not
to the level that it ought to be because
environmental factors and chemicals and
things like that play a role in it too
but no I don't I don't think that any uh
sort of good end would justify immoral
actions we're not we're not uh
consequentialists like the libs but but
in this case there are so many simpler
remedies than that okay next question
hey Michael I'm a long time listener but
this is my first time submitting a
question for the mailbag I'm a
homeschooling Latin Mass mom of three
little girls
you had mentioned on your show the other
day about near occasions of sin and
that's a perfect segue into my question
for you
what do you think about people kissing
before they get married like even if
you're engaged and all of that to me
that's always seemed like a near
occasion of sin because I mean
you know what where kissing leads so
um just uh wanted to get your opinion on
that thanks and love the show
great question you might have seen my
heart was fluttering out of my chest
when you said I'm a Latin Mass attending
homeschooling mother who listens to your
show all the time so that's great and
not at all surprised by your extremely
Trad question is it okay to forget about
the other stuff people do before
marriage is it okay to kiss before
marriage I think it probably is
I think it probably is but I I take
seriously your fear here which is we all
know what kissing leads to
and that's true I guess it depends on
the kind of kissing and where you're
kissing and the circumstances of the
kissing that's true but we also know
where
going out to dinner leads you know going
out to dinner is that's what happens
before you start kissing and kissing is
what happens before you start you know
doing that other thing and then doing
that other thing is what happens before
you start doing that other thing is
you're definitely not supposed to do
before marriage so you know what one has
to have some Prudence here
and a kiss can be an elevating
experience I don't think that a kiss
necessarily needs to lead you into the
willful entertainment of impure thoughts
and desires I don't think that it
necessarily needs to lead you into a
committing a sinful act or anything
anything like that but it's something
you got to be careful of it's true
maybe we'll draw it Michael my name is
Courtney and I've been listening to you
for I don't know about a year or so now
I discovered you around the same time I
became a subscriber to daily wire
um anyways I have a cousin who just
posted on social media about a week ago
that he just became a certified Reiki
person or teacher or whatever you call
it and uh after watching your interview
with Angela I got very very
uncomfortable with this and I was just
wondering what
you thought I should do if I should just
pray for him talk to him something I'm
not really sure anyways
um love your show and can't wait to see
what you say thank you have a very very
Merry Christmas
thank you I hope that you have a very
merry Christmas as well yeah that's bad
juju your buddy should not be doing
Reiki stuff and he probably doesn't know
I mean I've I've known people and I've
had friends of friends who have gotten
into Reiki and they they don't know I
mean they're just hippies they don't
they don't know any better so yes I
would pray for your friend but I I
probably would confront him about it
depending on how close you guys are
um
you know you you could do it in a funny
way it doesn't have to be this very
somber oh you know I have been running
this over in my head for two weeks so
now we have to sit down and have an
intervention you could just say hey
buddy uh you know you're doing the Reiki
thing just so you know you're worshiping
demons and you shouldn't do that because
demons are real and they're very bad and
the thing you're doing is not good and
so bro just quit worshiping the demons
and like go to church and be a normal
person please
that that would be that that's one way
to do it it's kind of funny but it's
also true okay I want there's actually
more voicemail bag that I want to get to
we will get to it on the member block
but I don't want to leave without
getting into at least one
one real old-fashioned written mailbag
from Austin
hello Michael I'm 21 years old I have a
very conflicting situation at the moment
I have not uh so slowly watched my 12
year old sister go from first dating one
of her female friends to calling herself
non-binary
they're now starting to go by a guy's
name I'd like to speak up to my dad
about my problems with it however he's
always right and will call me uneducated
if I communicate my points in a less
than perfect manner I'm going home for
Christmas
and I fully expect to be corrected if I
say her pronouns are named the wrong way
any advice thanks for the great podcast
and Merry Christmas oh that's a tough
one Austin and it's weird that it's your
dad
who's really into all the weird trans
stuff
sometimes mothers are really into it but
usually dads are a little more
level-headed and not as brought in you
know emotionally on when their kids get
into weird sex stuff so that's that's
really bizarre it's really funny that
you are sort of the rational one in this
family of Libs but you know she's your
sister you have to love her and should
love her and you have to respect your
parents and honor your parents
but you can respectfully say you know
Dad this is really bad and it's going to
really screw up your daughter and here's
the evidence and hear all the D
transitioners you talk about what a
terrible thing this is and actually men
just can't become women and women can't
become men and I don't know if your
family has any even hint of religion but
you could say this is actually opposed
by the church and the church you know
and you guys you just lost it here and
and Dad and Mama and sis I'm happy to
love you and honor you as much as I
possibly can but you can't make me lie
okay so you don't need to walk in there
and host a screening of you know what is
a woman or anything like that but but
you you really can't lie
so I wouldn't use the pronouns you can
try to avoid it to keep the peace at
Christmas maybe you probably can't avoid
it though totally I I would just
one has to speak the truth in love so
make sure you do the love part but you
got to tell the truth
now speaking of Walsh
it is the season of Good Tidings and
cheer and
I am forced under duress and coercion
here by the daily wire and by some bets
that apparently we have made
to give just a really big shout out to
the old big Burly bearded Sweet Daddy
himself the one and only
Matthew Walsh his sweet baby gang is
second to no other
sweet baby gang
I just can't get enough of this guy this
is some who wrote this just ask a sweet
little Elisa she uh bought me a ton of
Mount Walsh merchandise for my birthday
now you're making me lie and this and
it's so good that I asked for more of it
for Christmas he's got this incredible
Super Fan gift bundle which
as a super fan myself I've been trying
to get my hands on the bundle comes with
a ton of what is a woman stuff and
cooking supplies and stickers and even a
Johnny The Walrus plushie I actually do
want a Johnny walrus plushie those are
great which if you haven't read it
Johnny The Walrus it's a great book
and uh it it's got words in it uh that's
nice that's nice that they put that in
there anyway I'm just so happy to be
buddies with Matt and I definitely was
not forced to say any of this because of
some election bet or whatever that I
don't even remember all of this comes
from the heart
and it's just a spur of the moment
inclination to give the man praise that
he deserves more than anybody else here
at the daily wire certainly deserves
more praise than whoever wrote this Matt
you're truly one of a kind
Matt wall Show streaming every Monday
through Friday 1 30 Eastern
dailywire.com
we got a lot more show coming up it's
fake headline Friday so we have got you
I need your help before you all go to
the airport and miss your flights
because the snowstorm is canceling every
flight in the country before you head
down hunker down and eat some nice
turkey or seven fishes if you're Italian
I need you to help me figure out which
is the fake headline for fake headline
Friday we've also got more voicemail
back we've also got more mailbag mailbag
the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]